okay let me ask you something that I'm
very curious about it
um I'm going to throw you some Asian you
know what I mean and you give me one
through ten of how you feel about the
race yes do you you want to play this
game yeah okay can I also comment you
can comment as well okay cool yeah let's
let's pick the game up together yeah
okay so let's go with um Korean one
through ten I would give Kring a 7.5
[__] great not great husbands because my
hairdresser oh yeah let's let's do it
through if you in terms of marriage okay
situation all right okay so still 7.5 in
a marriage situation yeah can I tell you
why first of all you they can be gay
they can dress me
the cream and not like it's not sexually
they have the gay fashion
you have the gay fashion mind wait wait
the gay fat but what's this the glasses
are they glasses no no way they see
things they put a scarf on you they will
discover you oh hilarious okay
the lens they would know how to dress
you yeah yeah because they have a taste
they are the only Asian men have a taste
left okay can I just have I ever tried
to dress you I don't think I have no but
we wear the same clothes oh yeah that's
true we haven't shared our closet yes he
has to wear my clothes yes yeah she made
it look amazing yeah but what about like
in in sexually you think we're good or
no I think they are creaming are like a
very uh crazy so I think they might be
good and bad yeah because you see the
three movies right yeah the best movies
like oh boy oh yeah yeah it's like yeah
yeah yeah that's how I come oh that's
great yeah so 7.5 yeah as a husband and
hairdresser
hairdresser is the best okay and this
happens okay Japanese
uh oh whoa whoa I have my special uh on
the Japanese uh NHK right now okay so I
would give Japan a 6.8
what's the point eight I love the like
Asia the specific point yeah and why six
point eight six eight six means lucky
eight means a lot of money so that's a
good number
oh well yeah
Japanese people they they are on time
you know I'm always late I mean they're
like Germans you know because they're on
time yeah that's why you can always rely
on their cars yeah their cars is good
and they are on time they know how to
really kill something
what do you mean like you know the
German and the Japanese you know
right in the back when they were crazy
right they got together yeah and they
you know I mean like to kill things
together yeah so
sure I'm on time to the babidi podcast
I see and then the Japanese food it's
good yeah I'm gonna throw you a
curveball now okay Eskimo
and I don't think it's a it's Inuit are
they Inuit my bad
wait wait they're not Asians do you want
like Asian countries no let's no let's
stop for a second okay
that when I lived in Minnesota right and
whenever it snowed the the white kids
would get ice balls right and y'all all
y'all Eskimo and they would throw
[__] you know I mean ice cubes at my
head so they were wrong
yeah so you would still consider them
Asians I think I heard they are from
China they just traveled from China to
wherever they are
you know they have our eyes oh so I'm
gonna adopt uh Eskimos Asians so what
would you rate them I'm not going there
it's too cold it's too cold I'm not
going there okay there's no there's no
stage there's no champagne there's no
lights I I'm attention seeking horror
I'm not gonna go to the Ice Cube
but I understand but you know your
holiday The Comedy Club you could do it
in an igloo too I don't want to go there
I want attention
for me oh okay okay so let's get rid of
them okay and let's go to uh one last
one what do you think what's a good one
let's do Filipinos I am very uh okay I'm
gonna give them like uh
7.8
yes because
we look at like you think you and I look
alike I have I talk about you in my
whole act I think all Asian women we are
literally like we have so many talents
so many talents Asian women yeah we can
we can do your homework we can fix your
computer we uh we can do everything we
need good good food but also we can all
take off our lashes and become Bobby Lee
yeah I can take this off and wear your
Benny I'll be you you you yeah you
wouldn't it's funny because I dated a
Korean girl once and in the darkness you
know how your eyes get adjusted to the
darkness right I went Mom right because
you could it conform into whatever it's
like going into you know I mean the
house of mirrors at a [__] you know
Carnival or whatever right you go oh
there's a fat version of me you know I
mean that's what so I get what you're
saying yeah yeah it will be the same
person
yeah yeah so Filipinos don't look like
you they don't look like Asians also
like I would never date a Filipino women
if I'm gay because they just they are
like the Asians but having like they
become like because they are mixed and
then they just have more the features we
want to have that we don't have yeah
yeah like you know they say like all
like they all the Indians and the
Filipinos they are all the beauty queens
Mr world Miss Universe all right people
they don't want that like you look like
this like you can just be like a Miss
China but you never become Miss World
but the Filipino girls they're just like
yeah and they just like they are just
and the Filipino man that's our show
yeah people we are the people that's our
TV people hate us like they would think
you are Chinese and spit on you but they
wouldn't never do that to her because
she could be she could be Mexican she
could be like a Jenny Jenny on the Block
right right God I never thought of it
that way right so basically sister
exactly I'm
[Laughter]
Chinese and Koreans do [__] on Filipinos
yeah because never out loud right no no
we don't see anything in public not on
the public especially the biggest
podcast in the world like yeah yeah we
do it privately babe but respect
no respect yeah but you know what it is
that we we can do this I'll be honest
okay we can do this if something happens
like uh oh Korea you know what I mean
attacked you know I mean Bangladesh or
whatever and and and Koreans were having
a bad you know what I mean rap I could
always say I'm Chinese yeah and you can
do the device vice versa so we can do
that we can change in that way yeah
right and also like you know all the
Indian friends they they like
everybody's ending other 9 11.
exactly Indian what are y'all talking
about
when Virginia Tech happened and that
Korean guy shot up that school I was
literally [__] Chinese for a year
yeah I don't know if you're trying to
leave Bruce Lee Bruce Lee yes right was
he not from China he's from Hong Kong
but it's now he's China they're not the
same now it's a part of China I mean not
technically trying to control the Hong
Kong let's not get specific
it's like have a hot take about Vanessa
Hudgens because you know that she's like
Filipina right yeah but she's never
claimed it until now that she knows
being Filipino is